En este video vamos a hablar sobre combinaciones
de transformaciones: homotecias, traslaciones
y rotaciones. Si no te acuerdas de qué es una
homotecia, te recuerdo que es una transformación
que amplía o reduce una figura, conservando las
proporciones. Imagina que en la sala de tu casa
hay un sofá y quieres situarlo al otro lado de
la sala, y con la orientación contraria, como
lo muestra esta pantalla. ¿Qué tendrías que hacer
para lograrlo? Pausa el video y piensa un poco en
ello. Hay muchas formas de llevarlo a cabo, pero
en este video vamos a usar las transformaciones
para hacerlo. Vamos a usar en tu sala este sistema
de coordenadas: un plano coordenado. Este polígono
representa a tu sofá en su posición original; los
vértices exteriores del sofá son A (2,3); B (6,3);
C (6,1) y D (2,1). Para llevarlo a su nueva
posición, primero vamos a rotarlo, de manera que
en su posición final quede de frente. Recuerda
que una rotación es una transformación rígida
que gira la figura sobre un punto sin cambiar su
forma. Vamos a rotar el sofá a 180 grados, pero
tenemos que rotarlo sobre uno de sus vértices.
Elijamos un punto; digamos que es el punto (6,3),
y vamos a hacerlo. Para que quede claro esto,
voy a mostrar cómo rota la figura poco a poco,
cómo pasa de su ubicación original hasta que ha
rotado 180 grados. Observa las coordenadas del
sofá original y del sofá rotado, ¿cómo cambiaron?
La nueva posición del sofá con una rotación
de 180 grados y el punto de rotación (6,3) es A'
(10,3); B' (6,3); C' (6,5); D' (10,5). Muy bien,
ya hicimos la primera transformación, pero
aún no hemos terminado, falta llevarlo al
otro lado de la sala. ¿Qué tenemos que hacer para
lograrlo? Pausa el video y piensa en cómo harías
esto. Muy bien, lo que debemos hacer ahora es
trasladarlo. Recuerda que una traslación es una
transformación rígida en donde la figura cambia
su posición arriba, abajo, izquierda o derecha,
pero no cambia su orientación, tamaño ni forma.
Como queremos llevarlo al otro lado de la sala,
que mide 10 unidades cuadradas, exactamente en
frente de su posición actual, debemos moverlo 1,
2, 3, 4 unidades a la izquierda en el eje X y
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 unidades hacia arriba en el Y,
es decir, haremos un traslado por -4,5. Todas las
coordenadas se moverán igual: -4 sobre el eje X y
5 sobre el eje Y. Voy a señalar el movimiento
con este vector. Recuerda que un vector es un
segmento de recta ordenado. Este vector apunta a
cuatro unidades a la izquierda y cinco unidades
arriba de su origen. Vamos a empezar con A'. A'
se mueve 4 unidades a la izquierda y 5 unidades
hacia arriba, queda aquí. B' se mueve 4 unidades
a la izquierda y 5 unidades hacia arriba, queda
acá. C' se mueve 4 unidades a la izquierda
sobre el eje X y 5 unidades hacia arriba sobre
el eje Y. D' se mueve... adivinaste: 4 unidades a
la izquierda y 5 unidades hacia arriba. Llevamos
el sofá a las nuevas coordenadas. Si observas
con atención, aplicamos varias transformaciones
sucesivas al mismo objeto porque hicimos
una rotación, una traslación en el eje Y y
una traslación en el eje X, así que, casi sin
darnos cuenta, hemos hecho una combinación de
transformaciones geométricas. Muy bien, el sofá ya
quedó en la posición deseada. Ahora, para terminar
de reacomodar la sala, sería muy buena idea poner
un tapete. Tenemos un tapete que mide 5 x 5, como
puedes observar. La proporción es la adecuada,
pero es muy pequeño ya que ahora quieres cubrir
toda el área. Recuerda que la sala mide 10 x 10
unidades. ¿Qué transformaciones necesitas hacer
al tapete para lograr lo que quieres? Pausa
el video e intenta resolverlo. Bien, vamos a
resolverlo juntos. Podemos hacerle una ampliación
al tapete, una homotecia para ampliarlo al tamaño
que queremos. Recuerda que las ampliaciones o
reducciones se realizan aplicando un factor de
ampliación o reducción. ¿Cuál será el factor
que requerimos para ampliar nuestro tapete?,
es decir, si el tapete mide 5 x 5, ¿cuál será
la cantidad por la que tendremos que multiplicar
estas dimensiones para que cubra toda el área
de 10 x 10? Parece que si multiplicamos por 2
obtendremos las dimensiones que deseamos para
el tapete. Veamos: 5 • 2 es 10, funciona, así
que el factor es 2. Vamos a hacerlo. Primero vamos
a ver las coordenadas de cada esquina del tapete:
E (7,6); F (7,1); G (12,1); H (12,6). Para la
ampliación sólo tenemos que multiplicar cada
valor en las coordenadas de las esquinas por 2.
Hagámoslo: E' es 7 • 2 = 14, 6 • 2 = 12, 14,12;
F' es 7 • 2 = 14, 1 • 2 = 2, 14, 2; G' es 12 •
2 = 24, 1 • 2 = 2, 24,2; y H' es 12 • 2 = 24,
6 • 2 = 12, 24,12. Usamos cada una de las nuevas
coordenadas y dibujamos el tapete ampliado. Muy
bien, ya ampliamos el tapete. Pero como puedes
ver nos ha quedado muy lejos de la sala,
hay que llevarlo a la posición que queremos, así
que la última transformación es trasladar esta
figura. En el plano coordenado, un lado de la sala
coincide con el eje Y y forma esquina justo en el
eje X. La esquina inferior izquierda de la sala
tiene coordenadas 0,0, así que queremos mover el
tapete hacia el origen del plano coordenado,
en específico queremos que la esquina F'
quede en el origen. Vamos a dibujar el vector que
representa el movimiento del tapete, es un vector
de 14 unidades a la izquierda y 2 unidades hacia
abajo, desde su origen. Hacemos la traslación,
y listo, ya tenemos el tapete que abarca toda
la sala, y de nuevo hicimos una composición
de transformaciones geométricas. Ampliamos el
tapete y lo trasladamos al lugar que queríamos.